bonsoir blanchemaison même si d'être
avec nous comment expliquer sa hotte
s'est auto spla grande de l'électricité
alors pour certains on l'a vu c'est
directement lié à la façon dont a été
consul marché européen de l'énergie est
ce qu'ils disent vrai
d'abord c'est un phénomène général c'est
à dire que partout dans le monde l'année
le prix de l'énergie augmentent pour une
raison très simple c'est que il y à une
reprise économique heureusement après la
période de repli dû aux propos vite dû à
la pandémie ensuite parce que
effectivement je crois qu'on peut dire
que il n'y a pas de marché de
l'électricité il n'y a pas de marché
unique monsieur le maire aurait pu aller
jusqu'au bout de sa pensée en disant
cela car chaque état membre a voulu
retenir deux choses d'abord sa liberté
de choisir son mixte économique comment
je fabrique pas de l'électricité
nucléaire ou pas nucléaire charbon pas
charbon pétrole ou pas pétrole gaz et
puis les énergies renouvelables à quel
rythme et ce que je les ai introduit
dans mon cocktail pour fabriquer
l'énergie nucléaire et chaque état reste
libre c'est un choix très politique et
par conséquent aucun état ne veut
délégué ce choix à bruxelles
probablement d'ailleurs à juste titre
deuxièmement également il n'y a pas de
marché parce que il n'ya pas
interconnexion des réseaux il ya une
directive une vieille directive
européenne qui dit que l'interconnexion
devrait être au niveau de 20% entre la
production de chaque état membre on en
est bien loin avec l'espagne par exemple
elle est environ de 4 à 5% donc il n'y a
pas possibilité électricité circule très
mal on ne sait pas stocker l'électricité
on sait stocker l'énergie primaire qui
sert à la fabriquer on ne peut pas
stocker en effet par ailleurs il ya
aussi des acteurs privés les grandes
compagnies pétrolières ou gazières qui
considèrent que leur aire de jeu n'est
pas l'europe n'est pas l'état manque
c'est le monde donc prise entre le
marché mondial et les états membres qui
gardent beaucoup de compétences en effet
l'union européenne est un petit peu en
lévitation et par conséquent essais
d'édicter des règles pour l'avenir pour
respecter des objectifs qui sont des
objectifs écologiques pour lutter contre
le réchauffement climatique mais qui
sont finalement assez marginaux par
rapport à la politique de fabrication de
l'électricité est à son prix qui en
effet est différent d'un pays à l'autre
d'ailleurs en france il est inférieur à
la moyenne de ceux qui vivaient dans les
pays de l'union européenne en allemagne
c'est beaucoup plus élevées et aux
dalles mars est également beaucoup plus
élevé alors l'ouverture du marché de
l'électricité à la concurrence à a été
qualifié par une association de
consommateurs on l'a vu dans le sujet
comme un échec je cite qui s'avère
nuisible pour le bien-être des
consommateurs
en quoi il est il oui en effet on peut
regretter la belle époque où edf
electricité de france gaz de france
était de monopole que les français mais
bien d'ailleurs est en effet certains
partis politiques regrettent cette
période il se trouve que le choix qui a
été fait est différent en effet sous la
pression de bruxelles le législateur le
parlement a décidé en 2000 de supprimer
le monopole d'edf et en 2006 de
privatiser gaz de france et donc par
conséquent d'autres acteurs
interviennent sur le marché et
je crois que à juste titre on remarque
en effet que les prix ont continué
d'augmenter peut-être même plus
rapidement qu'avant parce qu'il faut
entretenir le réseau parce qu'il ya des
frais de transport qui sont importants
parce qu'il faut s'ajuster à la demande
et par conséquent la concurrence n'a pas
apporté une baisse des prix sur le
marché français pas plus que sur les
marchés voisins dans les autres pays
d'europe où ils ont également beaucoup
augmenté alors le nucléaire qui semble
revenir en grâce à ans le voit ici ou là
même dans la bouche de certains verts en
face à cette hausse fulgurante des prix
que dit aucun branche maison cette crise
de l'avenir du nucléaire en europe subit
lundi qu on est à un moment de vérité
parce que en effet si l'on veut
respecter les objectifs écologiques la
commission voudrait que l'union
européenne soit neutre sur le plan
carbone en 2050 2050 c'est après demain
la coop 26 qui va se réunir au début du
mois prochain à glasgow
n'aboutira pas à un résultat de ce genre
parce que des pays comme la chine l'inde
les états unis s'y opposeront ces trois
pays consomme 60 % de la production de
charbon du monde par conséquent ils sont
pas du tout prêts à renoncer au charbon
et arriver à un objectif qui soit neutre
en carbone aussi rapidement ou s'ils
prennent un engagement ce ne sera pas
très sérieux car il sera pas suivie
d'effet alors en effet l'une des façons
les plus évidentes d'aller vers cet
objectif de neutralité carbone c'est de
recourir au nucléaire là dessus il y à
un désaccord entre les états membres de
l'union européenne ya aussi un désaccord
entre les partis politiques les verts
les écologistes sont hostiles à
l'énergie nucléaire et prenons les
devants dans le fond madame merkel a
organisé la sortie de l'allemagne du
nucléaire et par conséquent est bien le
recours accru au charbon pendant une
période transitoire et au gaz d'où
l'importance que nord stream 2 pour la
transition énergétique en allemagne je
note d'ailleurs que le représentant
permanent de la russie à bruxelles a
fait des déclarations à la presse ce
matin en disant qu' il avait de bonnes
raisons de croire que le kremlin avait
recommandé à gazprom d'augmenter ses
livraisons de gaz et s'il le dit c'est
qu'il a instructions de le dire par
conséquent je pense que la russie va
faire un geste pour deux ans le fonds
faciliter la résolution de ce problème
aussi parce que c'est l'intérêt de
personne que les états membres retourne
au charbon
évidemment pour nous nous avons 70 %
notre notre électricité qui est produit
par les 56 réacteurs nucléaires et en
effet je pense que on frappe de nouveaux
réacteurs plaide nucléaire peut être pas
uniquement les opère peut être des
petits réacteurs plus adapté à la
situation plus souple est également plus
facile à exporter merci beaucoup claude
blanchemaison pour cet éclairage